[Music]
all right everybody let me see your
puppy dog eyes your hard eyes what am I
asking for though like a [__] yeah
wow is that what you do you probably get
your dick sucked a yeah I cry when I get
a [__] I cry before I get the blow
job give me another blow job please can
you give me another blow job can I get
my dick St again please this is going to
be a very very warming heartwarming
story okay uh but it's going to start
off with a little danger okay there's
this moment that there's this very cute
very very warmhearted dog like kind of
like a golden retriever maybe looking
thing I don't know trying to get some
head no that more more warmhearted I
like golden retrievers they're very
happy that's my next dog oh that'd be
great this dog is getting chased by a
pack of feral dogs oh [__] no Ain that a
wolf lot of kyotes [__] coyotes feral
dogs are like
wild yeah kind of those are like feral
are they yeah I thinko cats so his dog
has no choice this very cute this very
very innocent dog lonely dog is no
choice and this [__] fending for his
life jumps into a little stream a little
river right and you think you think
maybe it's safe but then there's three
crocodiles no what the [__] what's the
movie hom word bound yeah yeah oh that
one a good one and r buch of porcupine
know how to swim is this Africa or
Florida such a good movie dude that
movie is hilarious cuz you're watching
like you're watching like a dog
like and then Michael J fox is voicing
over like like he's talking I think his
name is chance right yeah yeah but it's
like I love homb and Sass I haven't seen
a really good dog movie
airbud by this airbud right now is like
really bad no way it's the one that they
watch in jail better
better do you know how many airbuds they
have isn't there like 16 bro every sport
every sport football MMA too yeah yeah
they got UFC Bud UFC bu he fights a
bunch of pit haven't playing baseball
cuz they ran out of sports Mike Vick's
the star in that one so three crocodiles
are in this [__] river right Jesus
what do you think is going to happen I
don't know [__] gorilla's going to
come fight him
next I think the crocodile is going to
obviously try to eat the dog but then
the dog's like going to make fun of him
and say hey are you Chinese and then the
crocodile's like don't be racist F and
then they're going to be offended and
Chinese that's insane I'm going to guess
that that's
not I bet $1,000 that doesn't happen you
chese
cocodile it was it was assumed that the
Crocs would just mutilate the [__] out
of this poor innocent dog why you say
mutilate unless they're baby Crocs huh
they're like this small they weren't
baby Crocs what's bigger a gator is
bigger right Crocs are [__] you think
dogs are smarter than [__] let's just
keep it focus on the story for just one
more second okay okay what do you think
is the biggest
predator Joe all right that being said
in a wild unanticipated and magical
moment of what they call animal
empathy the crocodiles ended up
protecting this dog and were even
nudging using their snouts talk to them
all three of them this is homward bounds
we're nudging this dog to the other Bank
of the water away from the feral dogs
what the [__] are you talking maybe they
got maybe these Croc can I watch this
the video is not there only photos are
are here how they watch the photos how
do they even have photos of it who's
who's the photographer's in a tree I me
there's no video there's just photos
stop trying to debunk me right now okay
this Ste you just making this up yeah
dude is this a shitty Kevin Hart film
guys here you know what Nick you want to
host
no this
one check it out dude yeah tell them BR
incredible moment three crocodiles saved
the life of a dog that fell in the river
that's cute though bro there is a video
there is a video go click the video oh
no it's a guy fighting off a crocodile
with a frying pan [__] this actually
a really good video it is a good video
have you seen the video of this guy I
think he's probably in Florida yeah this
crocodile grabs his little puppy snack
yeah and his dude runs in there grabs
the crocodile pulls it out and pulls his
puppy out saves it but the crocodile
like this big it's a baby so freaky I
don't know [__]
freaky let's not try to bring up better
crocodile stories while we're I think
this is a better one that's good this is
a good one what I love about this is how
they say this is a case of sentient
behavior of the mugger resulting in
cross species emotional empathy which is
not a very extensiv investigative
Behavior yes you're just making the [__]
up yeah [__] Hightech empathy hey can
you just let it be warm and
inspirational we talk about [__]
death and disaster all damn day and
there's no windows in this [__]
office so it's it's really difficult it
is hard it is hard and the hen lights I
hate but I feel like some animals
protect other animals you know not all
the time but but what was in it for the
Croc maybe he got beef with the those
dogs yeah maybe it is rival maybe [__]
those dogs looks like a hero yeah I bet
some of the feral dogs will snatch up a
Croc common enemy common enemy you ever
SE Jaguars do that [__] that's kind of
you think the
dog your fights are crazy no fight to
the death picture yo the do does not
look the guy looking at the crocodile is
[__] hilarious [__] dog like that
[__] scared out of his mind it is
like a Disney movie though where he's
it's like the thing that you thought was
the scary thing ended up being your
friend oh I'm sorry I judged you the
other thing and Finding Nemo whose
[__] dog is that you know you know
what I'm saying that is wild I can't
tell that he's nudging him there but the
dog's obviously not bleeding so yeah
it's not underwater yeah it's not
getting [__]
crash on you just get
[__] [__] three blind Crocs or
some [__] yeah you got no smell yeah
they just thought it was like a
hippopotamus they thought it was another
Croc they thought it was a hippopotamus
I don't know dude hippopotamus is really
hairy is this in Florida no it's
actually in India Oh India oh they're
Buddhist Crocs maybe do that vegan yeah
yeah oh yeah Buddhist Crocs that
explains it in Bali there's so many wild
dogs like that looked like that dog so
maybe it's just kind of like that just a
wild dog all I'm saying this is a
magical moment and you guys haven't
clapped yet know it's very Disney I also
don't know how the [__] it happened
though that's [__] crazy I didn't
think about how there's no windows in
here we're cooped up here all day I
apologize I think I'm going to switch
like and go back to school and study
animal empathy it's a major yeah it
seems like we need more at Harvard of it
I think it's Prett tight we need one
expert about it yeah you know since I've
been watching more dog training videos I
think I could understand why this do you
watch a lot actually we did bring
I love it there's a gangster guy on Tik
Tok in Vegas he's so good a dog trainer
dude those guys are kind of amazing some
of them are really good I also found
this big old British guy who's really
good he does I follow him too when you
say they're really good though or or
gangster I should say is it like they
know how to just [__] whisper some
[__] and it's good or is it like they
that moment no it's energy or is it like
he went to jail and now he loves dogs CU
he need he's got CP Ted on his neck yeah
that's how I know dog saved his life
dude that's what he says probably I
don't know one time we did a JK show in
Tampa and then um the girl that brought
us out there the event organizer were
like don't you guys got like [__]
crocodiles and alligators and [__] here
and she goes yeah I got chased by one
after school I was like what the [__]
that's a Florida story she said she was
waiting for the bus and the [__]
crocodile popped out of nowhere and then
she's like those things go fast
substitute crocodile with like homeless
person that's la
that's true po we have a crocodile out
here crocodile that's very good I think
they go like 20 M hour on land maybe not
for long but they move out crocodiles or
crocodiles both both if they decide to
sometimes they don't huh crackheads are
fast they're faster than Olympic Runners
they're like they're like cheetahs
they're like 70 M hour I might be more
scared of getting chased by a crackhead
than a crocodile me too cuz you don't
know what their agenda is yeah a
crocodile I just run zigzags and I'm
[__] breaking his ankles I don't
think it works that way dude I could you
you don't think you can out Juke a
[__] CRA I don't know they can't can
they move laterally wild large animals
scare the [__] out of me not no nobody
says that like grizzly bears it's a
controvert no nobody say grizzly bear
different but he's out zigzagging a
[__] bear dog you hit him with the
little trying to AI him they're just oh
step right over him dude say I'm good
you're supposed to go
big everybody comes
out that's the Disney movie but if a
crocodile was chasing me I'm going
zigzags hard left bro they can't they
can't move like that Circle does seem
difficult for a Croc you're seen the
Croc move in a circle they whack you
with their tail right they're little
dinosaurs I see move like this though
when they got something in mou oh [__]
that's crazy that's scary dude they're
shredding Us in the
Cyclone hey one of those [__] dragon
giant lizard things or crocodile Koto
Dragon Koto dragon is different komoto
dragons are crazy but they got the
poison did you see them bite the [__]
deer they [__] slash you even just a
little bit and then you're starting to
paralyze Up full disease and how they
move they move so sneaky and fast and
they'll swallow you they won't even
[__] chew you they don't have teeth
right kimono dragon different brother
some teeth would you rather get eaten by
a python or get eaten by a c crocodile
probably python maybe python but then by
when you the python you're like this and
you're just like a [__] bro it's just
slowly going slowly but they put you to
sleep first I'd rather go okay I'm gone
and there's a chance that somebody will
find it slice open the belly and you you
come out all like hases that happen yeah
all the time they they're usually dead
still though yeah I but crocodile
they're shredding you up dude they have
put you in the water and [__] blend
you that is the single scariest way you
could die I think but but with a
crocodile they might do that with your
limb rip it off but you might have a
chance after that you don't some cats
like play with their food M yeah so I
think lion yeah I think that' be worse
yeah I think that'd be worse Panther
Jaguar Panthers you see I mean I person
death by lion or death by pacam hyenas
I'm taking my chance with a pack of
hyenas dud Hy but they start with your
[__] first yeah they go for the butt
but there's also like eight of them bro
when you say dog size they're like St
Bernard size I know but Think Of You'
seen a lion I've seen a lion at a zoo oh
they're big that's a Honda Accord but e
just elbow can fight a [__] lion I'm
not saying I'm going to fight any of
them but I feel like maybe I could get a
cut yeah maybe I could get one on hyena
have you seen a lion's nose yeah the
nose is this big they're huge the head's
like this it's too Booth they big have
you seen that uh those African guys they
have pet hyenas yeah yeah yeah yeah
those photos are so cool that's true
they ain't got no pet lions but there is
that one like the real Taran guy on IG
who like just Saudi Arabians have pet
lions all that stuff seems like the
worst idea all you hear about is people
dying Mike Tyson had a pet lion well no
tiger tiger tiger tigers are bigger than
lion the man or even monkeys they're
ripping people apart that's why you get
them as a baby chimpanzees I don't think
so it's my pet because it's one of the
greatest predators
[Music]
second